[Musique]
ce petit bout de terre s'appelle le ha
carabac mais à partir du 1er janvier
2024 il n'existe plus ces 30 dernières
années de pays l'Arménie et l'Azerbaïjan
se sont batttu pour ce territoire le
bilan plus de 36000 morts parfois sans
que cela ne fasse de bruit en France
plongé aujourd'hui donc dans l'histoire
d'un conflit tragique et méconnu aux
portes de l'Europe bon il faut déjà
qu'on débute par de petites
présentations juste ici c'est
l'Azerbaïdjan un état situé en Asie de
l'Ouest est au cœur du Caucase cette
région située entre la mer Noire et la
mer Caspienne l'Azerbaïdjan compte 10
millions d'habitants qui sont en grande
majorité musulman et depuis 30 ans
environ le pays cherche à développer son
économie et à renforcer son rôle sur la
scène internationale on a ensuite
l'Arménie un petit pays qui compte 2,8
millions d'habitants en très grande
majorité des chrétiens pendant très
longtemps ça a été un royaume très
puissant et d'ailleurs pour la petite
histoire dans l'Antiquité l'Arménie a
même été le premier royaume au monde à
devenir officiellement chrétien il faut
bien comprendre qu'il n'y a pas toujours
eu un état arménien mais par contre
depuis très longtemps donc il y a une
population arménienne qui s'est
retrouvée déplacée au fil des années et
puis impossible de parler de l'Arménie
sans parler du génocide arménien du
début du 20e siècle près de 1,5 million
d'Arméniens ont perdu la vie des
Arméniens tués par le mouvement jeune
turc à la tête de l'empire
la France et une trentaine d'autres pays
aujourd'hui reconnaî ce génocide mais ce
n'est pas le cas de la Turquie qui
reconnaît un massacre mais refuse de
parler de génocide l'Azerbaïdjan d'un
côté l'Arménie de l'autre côté et donc
au milieu le haut cararabach aussi
appelé arzar par les Arméniens c'est un
territoire situé en azerbaïjan qui fait
à peu près la taille d'un département
français il a été peuplé pendant près de
30 ans par 120000 habitants en très
grande majorité des Arméniens de
confession cré chrétienne ce qu'il faut
bien comprendre ici c'est que l'Arménie
considère que le hautkarabak est une
région centrale de son histoire d'autant
plus donc qu'il est peuplé d'Arménien
cependant on peut noter que ces
dernières années l'Arménie n'a pas
revendiqué directement le hakaraba comme
faisant partie intégrant de son
territoire mais d'où viennent ces
tensions pour bien comprendre de quoi on
parle il faut remonter loin dans le
temps et quand je dis loin ça veut dire
vraiment vraiment loin nous sommes au 4e
siècle avant JésusChrist alors vous vous
en doutez à l'époque les frontières ne
sont pas les mêmes mais la région du
hakaraba qui ne s'appelle pas encore
comme ça est déjà peelé d'Arménien
c'était une province une des 12
provinces arméniennes et donc vous avez
des vestiges qui datent de cette époque
4e siècle 5e siècle 6e siècle et cetera
donc c'est oui c'est une terre
considérée comme arménienne si on avance
un petit peu dans le temps au début du
19e siècle une guerre entre l'Empire
russe et l'Empire perse éclate la région
du carabak ainsi que quasiment tout le
territoire actuel de l'Azerbaïjan passe
sous la domination de la Russie 20 ans
plus tard l'Arménie elle aussi passe
sous domination russe en 1905 la région
du caucas donc la région à cheval entre
l'Europe et l'Asie et donc sous
domination de la Russie et plus
précisément d'ailleurs sous domination
du tzar Nicolas II sauf que et bien en
1917 l'Empire russe s'effondre
l'Azerbaïjan l'Arménie mais aussi la
gérorgie deviennent donc indépendant et
le haut carabak commence à être disputé
entre d'un côté les Arméniens et de
l'autre côté les azerbaïjanais lors de
cette période à la chute de l'Empire
russe il y a plusieurs épisodes violents
notamment les massacres de shushi une
ville du hakarabak durant lesquels
environ 20000 civils Arméniens furent
tués des quartiers Arméniens de la ville
ont également été entièrement détruit
c'est donc une période importante à la
chute de l'Empire russe qu'il faut
retenir mais attention car en 1920
nouveau bouleversement la République
socialiste fédérative soviétique de
Russie qui n'est pas encore l'URSS prend
le contrôle de l'Azerbaïdjan en avril
puis de l'Arménie en novembre les deux
pays deviennent alors des républiques
socialistes soviétiques en juillet 1921
Joseph Staline le dirigeant soviétique
de l'époque décide d'accorder à
l'Azerbaïdjan deux territoires qui
étaient donc historiquement peuplé
d'Arméniens en effet le haut Caraba et
le nakichevan ce petit territoire TER
que vous voyez juste ici situé au sud de
l'Arménie ces deux territoires donc
deviennent des territoires de
l'Azerbaïdjan à l'époque il faut bien
comprendre que cette décision de Staline
elle fait l'effet véritablement d'un
tremblement de terre elle est
immédiatement contestée par les
Arméniens en effet les Arméniens
représentent à ce moment-là 94 % de la
population du haut carabach et donc
c'est véritablement de cette décision de
Staline que sont né beaucoup des
tensions que l'on connaît encore
aujourd'hui donner le cararabak à
l'Azerbaidjan c'est cassé le
nationalisme arménien parce que Staline
s'en méfie pour des raisons de pur
cynisme politique à vouloir diviser
encore une fois pour régner pour résumer
donc l'Arménie estime alors que le
hakarabak est une région centrale de son
histoire et de son peuple mais en 1921
elle est accordée à l'Azerbaïdjan par
les Soviétiques à partir de 1921
commence donc une parenthèse soviétique
qui va durer une soixantaine d'années
pendant cette période le haokaraba
bénéficie du statut de régionut ome donc
il possède un parlement des organes
locaux et cetera mais cependant donc
vous l'urez compris il reste rattaché à
la République d'azerbaïjan qui fait
partie donc de l'URSS à chaque fois que
le régime soviétique s'est
libéralisé par exemple à la mort de
Staline et bien les Arméniens du du du
Kabak ont demandé leur attattachement à
à la république soviétique d'Arménie les
Arméniens du arabas sentent alors qu'ils
sont discriminés par la république
soviétique d'Azerbaïdjan les autorités é
azerbaïdjanaise restreignent les liens
entre le hautkarabach et l'Arménie ils
mènent aussi une politique de
désarménisation de la région en
déplaçant des populations arméniennes en
dehors du
hautkabak alors à quand remontent les
premières guerre du hakaraba le 20
février 1988 le Parlement du haaraba
officialise sa demande de rattachement à
l'Arménie quelques jours plus tard le 26
février c'est 1 million de personnes qui
défilent à à Erevan la capitale de
l'Arménie pour demander que le
hautkarabak devienne bien un territoire
arménien mais entre le 27 et le 29
février 1988 des dizaines de civiles
Arméniens sont massacrés à sumgait en
azerbaïjan par les forces de l'armée
azerbaïdjanaise la situation empire
d'autant plus avec la chute de l'URSS en
1991 bien l'Arménie comme l'Azerbaïdjan
redeviennent de fait indépendant et le
hakarabak lui aussi veut faire de même
la province se déclare donc indépendante
mais cette indépendance n'est pas
reconnue par la communauté
internationale notamment aucun membre de
l'ONU et d'ailleurs elle n'est pas non
plus reconnue par l'Arménie et forcément
de son côté l'Azerbaïdjan ne voit pas
d'un très bon œil cette déclaration
d'indépendance de la part du haut
karabak et donc l'Azerbaïdjan décide
d'envoyer ses troupes dans le Haut
Karabakh pour reprendre le contrôle de
ce qu'il estime être cétare cette
situation conduit à des affrontements
violent entre les séparatistes Arméniens
qui veulent donc l'indépendance du haut
karabak et les soldats de l'Azerbaïdjan
au fur et à mesure du conflit les
séparatistes Arméniens sont même épaulés
par des soldats de l'Arménie qui
viennent combattre à leur côté les
combats se poursuivent jusqu'à
l'instauration d'un cess lefeu en 1994
un cess lefeu négocié par le Groupe de
Minsk le Groupe de Minsk peut-être que
vous en avez déjà entendu parler c'est
une assemblée composée de nations
européennes et des États-Unis qui a été
créée pour pour faciliter justement des
négociations dans le cadre de ce conflit
en tout cas en 3 ans le bilan est
absolument terrible puisque 30000
personnes sont tuées et certes les
sources varient et les pertes sont
difficiles à chiffrer mais on compterait
environ 6000 morts côté arménien et
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de morts
du côté de l'Azerbaïdjan et au-delà de
ce bilan humain très important il y a eu
également près d'un million de déplacés
environ 400000 Arméniens qui sont
retournés en Arménie qui sont partis en
Russie une Russie qui soutient l'Arménie
mais il y a aussi donc près de 800000
azerbaïdjanais qui vivaient en Arménie
qui sont allés en Azerbaïdjan sachant
que beaucoup ont été placés à l'URE dans
des camps de réfugiés vous l'aurez
peut-être compris à l'époque c'est donc
l'Arménie avec les séparatistes
Arméniens qui remportent cette guerre
face à l'Azerbaïdjan ils prennent alors
le contrôle d'environ 13 % de ce
quiétait le territoire azerbaïdjanais à
l'époque à ce moment-là l'Azerbaïdjan
n'a qu'une une seule obsession et c'est
ce qui va mener à deux autres guerres
prendre sa revanche d'abord et puis
reconquérir certains territoires qui ont
été récupéré par les Arméniens c'est le
cas notamment donc du au Kabak et là il
faut comprendre que des moyens
absolument colossaux vont être mis en
place par l'Azerbaïdjan entre 2008 et
2019 l'Azerbaïdjan dépense 24 milliards
de dollars en équipement militaire c'est
six fois plus tout simplement que
l'Arménie qui dépense à l'époque à peine
5 milliards alors comment l'expliquer et
bien l'Azerbaïdjan est un important
producteur de pétrole et la hausse des
prix du pétrole au début des années 2000
a entraîné une augmentation importante
de ces moyens pour donc mener cette
guerre face à l'Arménie pendant de
nombreuses années les deux pays vont
donc maintenir des forces militaires sur
le terrain et des accrochages ont lieu à
plusieurs reprises en avril 2016 par
exemple de violents affrontements ont
lieu dans le haut carabak faisant
environ 130 morts côté arménien et 550
côté azerbaïdjanais en 4 jours seulement
cependant je pense que vous commencez à
le comprendre à ce jour là aussi le
bilan exact et dur à vérifier en raison
donc des sources variaable on arrive
alors à des combats qui sont beaucoup
plus récents que vous avez peut-être
suivi d'ailleurs dans nos formats des
actu du jour qu'on a fait sur Youtube
depuis quelques années maintenant le 27
septembre 2020 l'Azerbaïjan lance une
offensive majeure dans le haut karabak
c'est le début officiellement de la
deuxème guerre du okaraba qui va durer
au total 44 jours à ce moment-là il y a
un pays dont on a quasiment pas parlé
depuis le début mais qui intervient dans
le conflit ce pays c'est la Turquie en
effet en voyant un nouveau front
s'ouvrir dans le haut cararabak et bien
la Turquie voit notamment une nouvelle
opportunité pour se positionner face à
un rival important à savoir la Russie
qui est plutôt proche de l'Arménie face
à l'Arménie et un soutien relatif venant
de la Russie et bien la Turquie décide
donc de soutenir militairement
l'Azerbaïdjan les combats vont donc
faire rage et un cesser lefeu est
négocié par la Russie et signé le 9
novembre 2020 un cesser le feu qui est
considéré par l'Azerbaïdjan comme une
capitulation de l'Arménie et cet accord
n'aboutit pas à une paix claire et
stable mais il met fin à l'époque à des
combats meurtriers faut comprendre qu'on
parle à l'époque de près de 6500 morts
au total selon les différents chiffres
officiels mais à ce moment-là le
président azerbaïjanais Ilam alief ne
veut pas se contenter uniquement de
cette victoire militaire il veut aussi
une victoire territoriale il veut
récupérer complètement le haut carabach
des séparatistes Arméniens il souhaite
en gros donc que le hakarabak ne fasse
plus qu'un avec l'Azerbaïjan pour
accélérer cette reconquête l'Azerbaïdjan
va donc mettre en place le 12 décembre
2022 un blocus du corridor de lachtin le
corridor de lachtin faut bien comprendre
que c'est la seule route qui relie le
hakaraba à l'Arménie à l'époque les
habitants du hakaraba ne peuvent plus
circuler libre ils font face à de
nombreuses pénuries que ce soit de
nourriture ou encore de médicaments et
la situation est réellement
catastrophique d'un point de vue
humanitaire même les véhicules
humanitaires d'ailleurs ne peuvent plus
pénétrer dans le haut carabac selon
l'ONG Amnesty internationale la
situation est particulièrement
catastrophique pour les personnes âgées
ou alors les personnes en situation de
handicap car l'accès au Service de Santé
est extrêmement limité et toujours selon
Amnesty internationale à l'époque les
chirurgiens ne peuvent tassurer que 10 %
des opérations dans les hôpitaux à cause
du manque de matériel en février 2023
c'est la Cour internationale de Justice
l'organe judiciaire principale de l'ONU
qui ordonne à l'Azerbaïdjan de mettre
fin au
blocus comment est-ce que le haarabak a
pu disparaître le 19 septembre 2023
l'armée azerbaïdjanaise lance une
offensive éclaire de 24 heur dans le
haut carabak pour justifier
officiellement cette offensive
l'Azerbaïjan évoque la mort de qu
policiers et de deux civils
azerbaïdjanais dans l'explosion de mines
sur un chantier dans le haut cararabak
une explosion qui l'associie à un groupe
de saboteurs des séparatistes Arméniens
cette offensive estclaire et qui est
donc récente a fait 213 morts et près de
400 blessés chez les séparatistes
Arméniens et 193 morts côté
azerbaïdjanais majoritairement des
militaires elle mène finalement à
l'autodissolution des autorités et du
Parlement présent au Kabak une
autodissolution qui sera acté au bout de
24 Hees en effet les séparatistes
Arméniens qui contrôlaient donc le
hautkarabak refusent d'être intégré à
l'Azerbaïdjan résultat en l'espace d'à
peine 2 semaines la quasi totalité de la
population du hautkaraba fu en Arménie
avec des images parfois impressionnantes
de fuite massiv l'Arménie dénonce alors
un nettoyage ethnique orchestré par
l'Azerbaïdjan on en vient donc à ce que
l'on évoquait en début de vidéo le 1er
janvier 2024 le haut karabak est donc
officiellement rattaché à l'Azerbaïdjan
ce qui veut dire qu'il n'y a plus de
pouvoir séparatiste sur place il n'y a
plus non plus d'État autoproclamés la
capitale du okaraba a d'ailleurs changé
de nom pour prendre un nom azeri ran
Keny plutôt que Stepanakert le nom
arménien qu'elle avait jusqu'ici c'est
donc la fin du haut cararabak arménien
tel qu'il était connu et maintenant que
va-t-il se passer alors aujourd'hui
beaucoup beaucoup d'Arméniens estiment
que le hautkarabach n'était qu'une
première étape et que une partie du
territoire de l'Arménie et la prochaine
cible de l'Azerbaïdjan le sud de
l'Arménie est particulièrement ciblé car
il est enclavé entre l'Azerbaïdjan à
l'Est et à gauche la région du
nakitchevan qui est un autre territoire
azerbaïdjanais selon l'Arménie
l'objectif à terme de l'Azerbaïdjan ce
serait de relier le nakitchevan avec le
reste du territoire de l'Azerbaïjan ce
qui lui permettrait d'avoir un lien et
une route plus simple avec la Turquie la
Turquie donc allié de l'Azerbaïjan et
qui partage une frontière avec le
nakichevan et cette inquiétude de
l'Arménie elle se matérialise par une
chose c'est un projet de corridor de
zangzour c'est son nom c'est en fait une
route qui traverserait tout le sud de
l'Arménie d'Est en Ouest le long de la
frontière avec l'Iran au sud le
président de l'Azerbaïjan insiste depuis
des années pour la création de cette
route pour relier donc ces deux
territoires mais de son côté l'Arménie
refuse catégoriquement car elle n'aurait
pas de droit de regard sur ce corridor
et par ailleurs on peut noter qu'au-delà
d'une simple route il y a des projets
plus vastes on peut citer notamment un
projet de gazoduc de 85 km mais aussi la
construction d'un complexe militaire
enfin dernier acteur qu'il faudra
surveiller dans les prochaines années la
question de l'Iran en effet il faut
comprendre que l'Iran livre beaucoup de
gaz à l'Arménie la crainte donc du côté
de l'Arménie c'est que ce corridor et
cette route entre le nakichevan et
l'Azerbaïjan et bien coupe finalement
l'Iran de l'Arménie en tout cas
aujourd'hui l'Arménie s'inquiète d'une
nouvelle menace de son intégrité
territoriale et Emmanuel Macron
d'ailleurs a réagi le président français
a déclaré dans un entretien télévisé en
septembre 2023 que la France était je
cite très vigilante à l'intégrité
territoriale de l'Arménie vous l'aurez
compris le conflit pourrait donc entrer
dans une nouvelle dimension dans les
prochaines années évidemment on suivra
ça de façon méticuleuse dans notre
format des actu du jour n'hésitez pas du
coup à vous abonner à cette chaîne
Youtube des grands formats et à la
chaîne youtube Des actues du jour un
immense merci à gides mination pour son
temps précieux et merci aussi beaucoup à
Blanche qui est journaliste au sein de
l'équipe et qui a travaillé sur ce sujet
qui vous l'aurez compris est très
complexe on espère que cette vidéo vous
a plu on se dit à très
vite